all year long the uh
and and i've i've i'll admit i've got a
touch of various disorders and ocd is
one of them and it's been bothering me
this concept of having
fewer than 16 regular season games or
just any number of uneven games if
everybody plays 15
like 1987 fine if everybody plays nine
like 1982 fine it's bothered me that you
could have
some teams with 16 some with 15 some
with 14 and then you determine playoff
position based on winning percentage
and you would have someone inevitably on
the outside looking in saying
if we would have gotten to play one more
game or if the team ahead of us
had been forced to play one more game
maybe we get in
and they don't so i've been bothered by
that because in my mind that
undermines the integrity of the season
but when you look at what's going on for
me the tipping point was the broncos
game
we've already undermined the integrity
of the season by forcing
teams to go forward without enough
quarter without
any quarterbacks you have to play a game
with
zero quarterbacks you have to grab a
practice squad receiver on roughly
24 hours notice and get the guy ready
and look the broncos have said all the
right things because i don't think
anybody wants to be in the crosshairs of
345 park avenue right now
i think that within the walls of the
broncos facility there are some people
who are
very pissed off and there are some
people who think that they got screwed
one of the reasons they think they got
screwed
they're the ones who self-reported the
video of the quarterbacks
in the meeting room for an approved
meeting even though
someone from somewhere leaked it was an
unsanctioned meeting it was an approved
meeting
and there was an issue for a small
period of time with masks
and that becomes all of your
quarterbacks are on the covet 19 reserve
list
and my understanding is that the broncos
informed the league of that on friday
and it was like 30 hours later when they
finally heard they won't have their
quarterbacks gee thanks a lot
for giving us a fair opportunity to get
someone else ready to play so
it's just it for me that's the moment
where
i've come to the conclusion i don't care
if there aren't enough games
if there aren't an even number of games
there's already enough games because we
had nine per team
in 1982 everybody's got at least 11 now
except for
the teams that still are left to play
this weekend so
we're fine it's it's we're past the top
of the fifth for the rain out in the
baseball game shereen i'm not going to
obsess
over whether or not one team gets to 16
one team gets to 15 one team gets to 14.
the hay is in the barn let's just do
what we can to be fair to everyone to be
safe and courteous and respectful to the
players and let's just hope that
they get into a bubble by the time the
post season rolls around so we don't
have these issues every day every day
every day
well and remember mike we're going to go
to the extra playoff teams too if if we
do if that scenario does play out we're
going to have what eight teams in
in each conference that go to the
postseason so
if if you're not in that top eight you
probably don't deserve to go to the
playoffs anyway
so you know the expanded playoffs are
probably going to take care of that i'm
with you
i would have rather have seen the
broncos game postponed for a day or two
or completely wiped off the schedule
whatever you have to do but that was not
a competitive game it was not worth
watching
i watched maybe two or three series of
that one just
out of curiosity of what the broncos
were gonna do but like he said they
didn't have enough time to prepare
even to go to a wildcat type offense or
whatever they were going to do they
didn't have time to prepare for that and
and so it was blatantly unfair to the
broncos what happened
now you can put it on them that they're
the ones that took the mask off in the
meetings
whatever you want to do but it was not a
competitive game
no one expected the broncos to go in
there and win with no quarterback and
they certainly didn't they got blown out
by the saints who
what didn't even have 100 yards passing
so it was a
useless game and they've they're
probably been now what
two or three of these games when you
just knew one team was going in there
with absolutely no chance because of the
covet issues that they had
and i think we're looking at that same
scenario for the ravens against the
steelers even
if the game's played on wednesday i'm
not giving the ravens
any chance to win this game on wednesday
zero they will get blown out
it was funny uh only because funny is
the best way to react
uh because if you don't laugh you end up
crying earlier today on pft live we
pivoted from talking about
the battle between the current goat and
the future goat
two broncos saints with a receiver
playing quarterback for one team and a
tight end playing quarterback for the
other team although i
continue to be a a taysom hill fan i'm
not going to
sacrifice a good joke just because i'm a
taysom hill fan
updated news from albert breer of si.com
the ravens plan to fly to pittsburgh
tuesday night
after they find out about their covet
testing
for tomorrow the ravens one of the teams
that is sufficiently close to the
testing laboratory that they get their
results
far earlier than others some teams don't
find out until
early morning the next day the ravens
usually find out by
5 pm eastern sometimes 6 o'clock
sometimes in that window
of what and it's obviously expedited now
because of their situation
there was one additional positive today
it was someone on injured reserve my
understanding is it's someone that they
expected as they deal with this tail end
of the outbreak
from last week but they want to see if
there's any more positives tomorrow
before they put everyone in a plane and
actually the plan is to use two planes
not that that makes it any better but
at least you can spread out a little bit
more in two planes
and there likely will still be some
trepidation if there are any remaining
positives tomorrow
but that's the plan for now it continues
to be fluid and it just shows you how
determined the nfl
is to get all the games played that they
haven't just said
forget it we're not playing this game or
we're postponing it indefinitely with
the possibility
that we'll play at week 18 assuming
there isn't a better option available
involving one of these two teams
and mike this is a team that hasn't
practiced in the last 10 days either
presumably they're on the field now
getting some work in but they haven't
had a full practice in 10 days so
it's incredible that you're asking them
to go play a football game
an nfl team going to play a football
game with
20 guys i think we're up to 20 or close
to 20 guys
on the covet list over the past week
more than 30 in the organization have
tested positive and they're going to
play a game
on wednesday practice or not starting
quarterback or not
starting offensive line or not get out
there and and go play
yeah and uh we'll just see how it all
continues to play
out and they have had walkthroughs and
this is part of the problem this is one
of the reasons why they ended up being
shut down trying to get the game in
thursday the league
let them have a walk through last monday
despite
knowing there were multiple players who
played on sunday against the titans who
were positive mark ingram and j.k
dobbins and then the league let them
gather on tuesday for a walk through
knowing that there had been positives
from monday and it wasn't until they
they figured out that the situation was
getting worse not better on tuesday that
they shut the facility so
they they almost got a full practice in
last tuesday walk through and it's going
to be a walk through tonight they're not
going to go out there and
and you know put on the pads and and do
that they're just trying to get
themselves mentally ready
to run their offense and their defense
against the steelers but you're right at
the end of the day
and and i don't i don't want to paint
myself into a corner on this and say
there's no way in hell the ravens can
win because who knows in the national
football league and they do have an
actual quarterback playing
not a converted receiver in rg3
and rg3 has had success in the past but
i'd be stunned if this game's even
competitive we'll watch it because it's
football and it's on tv
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports